que magali stobart ça les psychologues
bonjour merci d'être avec nous en direct
sur rt france alors vous êtes parti
voter ce matin pouvez vous nous décrire
la situation dont les bureaux de vote
alors on le rappelle que le pays est
confiné
effectivement c'est il y avait déjà du
monde le matin il s'est passé que ya eu
un petit moment de tension dans les
files dans la file parce qu'il y avait
soit disant pas de personnes pour le
pour le sur les tables de vote
mais en fait ce qui se passe c'est qu'il
n'ya qu'une table de vote à l'endroit
c'est à dire on est destiné à les voter
à certains lieux et en fait il n'ya
qu'une table où on peut voter
normalement on a plusieurs tables
plusieurs salles et là on n'y en a
qu'une donc effectivement ça fait tout
de suite des files d'attentes longue
mais tout est vrai tout est avec
restriction de avec notre qui tombe bien
avec notre stylo notre masque et on vote
alors selon vous un an les portugais ont
préféré rester c'est eux que prendre le
risque de se déplacer pour aller voter
bon comme vous avez dû entendre avec
dans la pièce qui a été passé
effectivement la semaine dernière il ya
déjà eu une voix un vote anticipation
par anticipation et qui a été très très
très accepté cependant il ya eu beaucoup
de monde qui a attendu il ya eu des gens
qui sont même partis tellement il y
avait trop d'attentes
donc je suppose que avec cette division
d2 de table de vote que ce soit plus
facile qui est moins deux et que tout le
monde puisse voter c'est très important
qu'on n'est pas un second tour alors
d'ailleurs pas de second tour parce que
le président sortant 1 est en tête des
sondages donnent même gagnant comme vous
l'avait dit dès le premier tour
certains parlent d'une élection sans
surprise pouvez vous nous expliquer
pourquoi il jouit d'une telle cote de
popularité certains médias parler de lui
il ya quelques temps du président le
plus populaire d'europe
pas si c'est plus populaire mais c'est
vrai que c'est un homme très populaire
et qui est très humain donc mais il n'ya
pas dessus de certitudes qui va être
voté au premier tour c'est bien pour ça
que tout le monde vote mais surtout
l'important c'est qu'il ya un premier
vote et qu' il n'y ait pas une deuxième
élection parce que sinon les gens sont
en confinement et ça crée beaucoup
d'instabilité les gens en ont marre
il ya déjà une d'être est très forte au
portugal qui était déjà dû au premier
confinement et qui se maintient
maintenant avec le deuxième faux
peaufinement avec une accoutumance plus
forte une une indifférence qui est dû à
la prolongation de nos de nos
confinement malheureusement et on va
rappeler ses six freins plus de 80000
contagion et près de 1400 morts au cours
de la dernière semaine écoulée sap et du
portugal presque le premier pays en
nombre de nouveaux cas et de décès par
rapport à sa population
pouvez vous nous dire quel est l'état
d'esprit peut-être même la sq il ya une
détresse psychologique au portugal ah
oui tout à fait on est tout à fait
conscient que les la détresse existe non
pas seulement à cause de la pandémie qui
est déjà qui met en risque tout toute la
population et de devoir avoir tous ces
gestes barrières que tout le monde et ça
et de maintenir mais il ya aussi toute
la question socio économique qui crée de
la précarité très élevé et je pense que
cette détresse va amener à beaucoup de
2k et de perturbations mental il est si
bien que le président de l'ordre des
psychologues ici au portugal
alerte pour cette question depuis le
premier confinement et qui a été ouvert
un service
national d'appui psychologique par
téléphone justement pour essayer de
donner un appui à tous ces personnes qui
n'ont pas les conditions pour être
suivis par le système national
merci en tout cas vous magali stobart
son appel vous êtes psychologue merci
d'avoir répondu à nos questions depuis
lisbonne au portugal